je n'ai pas de réponse scientifique
puisque par définition nous n'avons pas
encore le retour exact de l'intégralité
des personnes que nous avons
interpellées je veux ici vous dire que
le Président de la République a demandé
aux garder souhaits à moi-même de
postérieur à aux interpellations au
travail de la justice de faire très
rapidement une étude sociologique pour
savoir qui sont ces personnes
et je suis certain que le Président de
la République nous autorisera à rendre
public cette étude sociologique je veux
dire en dehors du travail des policiers
des gendarmes que des gens extérieurs
puissent regarder ce qui s'est passé
moi je n'y ai pas vu j'ai fait une
quinzaine de commissariats en 4 jours la
nuit et la première chose que je fais
quand je me pose de garde c'est que je
demande la liste des personnes qui sont
perdues et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
jusqu'à présent bah beaucoup dit que
c'était des gens pour violence
intrafamiliales on peut tous faire
l'expérience vous êtes parlementaire
vous aider quand vous le souhaitez bien
évidemment ça va la République j'ai
regardé et faites-le dans vos
commissariats dans vos brigades
gendarmerie qui sont ces gens oui il y a
des gens qui apparemment pourraient être
issus d'immigration mais il y a eu
beaucoup de Kevin et Matteo si je peux
me permettre
il y en a eu aussi et l'explication
n'est pas n'est pas
l'explication seulement identitaire me
paraît très erronée
je ne veux pas ici dire je pense qu'une
explication
identitaire serait se laisse tromper et
puis surtout je pense que ce serait une
critique assez fort de ce qui s'est
apparemment parce que si je fais un
rapide calcul 17 ans de moyenne c'est à
dire qu'ils sont nés sous la présidence
de Jacques Chirac ça veut dire que
reprocher aujourd'hui imaginez légiférer
immédiatement sur une question
migratoire
me paraît déjà trop tard madame la
sénatrice si jamais c'était votre
solution en revanche la question de
l'intégration et la réussite de
l'assimilation est une question
intéressante
et je crois que la posée simplement en
termes d'identitaire serait une réponse
trop facile mais encore une fois ce que
je dis tout à l'heure il faut il faut se
poser sur les sur les questions